with that reasoning in mind we might
expect the keyword this to be
inaccessible from the global scope as
well instead however the language has
historically been set up so that you can
refer to this from the global scope and
doing so gives you that default binding
which is to the global object this is
another confusing aspect of the language
and luckily that behavior was removed in
the more modern specifications of the
language finally I'd like to cover one
last way that the parameter this gets a
different sort of binding the pattern
we're about to see here is built to
support mechanisms we haven't explored
yet and we'll look at in more detail in
the lesson on pseudo-classical classes
in this situation we're calling our
function with the keyword new before it
and that will have an effect on how the
keyword this receives its binding the
positional parameters are of course
unaffected by the keyword new they get
passed along in exactly the same way as
they always are but the binding for the
keyword this is likely to surprise you
it's quite possible you've encountered
discussions on the Internet of how the
keyword new works and if so you might
take a moment to conjecture what you
think the binding for this might be
under these circumstances